[Music]
shot used to buy some senators vouchers
mr. Creech Brandon
may people fill any other way with this
two hands finish here well PJ Tucker and
yes that is your starting point guard
for the Memphis Grizzlies shot clock to
five
Marantz up in the air shot clock to two
puts up the face veteran play right
there by rookie are you kidding me
electric this
you couple the skies
[Applause]
then what they were able to put together
it's nice to have a guy partner that
jumps so well even when the love is not
good it makes the highlight look better
but look we catch the ball missed the
ball nowhere near the best look and it's
a lob from midcourt look at the head
balance no rebound Caribes out to
Anderson here is Moran turning on the
burgers
[Music]
[Applause]
handle and playmaking attack and kiss it
off the window
oh my job this here to the second trial
on the hill off the pump fake Moran with
a pump fake better hit down Oh whoopsie
Oh Rome Robinson yeah hand that boo
looking down whoa whoa whoops whoops
where'd he go where'd he go let me
compose myself and then knock you down
he had to come up with he had to compose
himself first because after you make the
move it's like okay Porter five to shoot
my rant works against Craig on the face
line still with it
[Applause]
did we just see
something amazing just an impossible
angle with the tenth of a second
remaining summer squeezed between glory
and mpj Joker's hair as well
you think that
most control of the basketball and
afterwards he gets that control for the
C's part the athleticism takes over the
highlight finish produced
[Music]
what's the young fella hit you back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crosses them going away from the basket
throws it in
what up at your boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report